[Music]
no one trolls kim kardashian harder than
her own daughter northwest
you just gotta roll with it on wednesday
the eight-year-old called out her mom
for seemingly using a different voice
when she posts to social media having
kids is just there's no way to describe
it but it's a lot the whole thing went
down when the kkw beauty founder was
talking on her insta story about a
beauty box she received what do you talk
differently why do i talk different for
what when i do videos for my videos i'm
the same human being i don't talk
different
how do i talk different
guys do you think they talk different
when i'm talking about contour yeah
yeah so even kim's sister kourtney
kardashian's nine-year-old daughter
penelope agreed
you do two penelope how do i talk guys
so today i got this new mask and these
small bronzers i got this
is that what you is that what i say is
that what i sound like
the 40 year old's reality star captioned
the clip quote this is how it's going
and later she posted a screenshot of
some tweets from fans laughing right
along with them
it's always so much fun
but this isn't the first time north has
trolled her famous mom online i don't
know how you're going to top that back
in may she interrupted kim while the
mama 4 was trying to show off some swag
she received from olivia rodrigo to
promote the singer's album sour
but north was having none of it i can't
wait for her album you guys know i love
driver's license
look she sent a box of tissues
yeah she straight up just called kim out
saying she never actually listens to the
track they would say that was like so
inappropriate yes i do i listen to it
all the time
stop north st don't we listen to in the
car all the time yes can you say that
louder for the people to hear do i
listen to it all the time saint yeah see
you guys
what a cutie
thank you
and kim she captioned the clip with an
all caps north and a series of laughing
crying emojis of course kim shares north
saint chicago and psalm with her
estranged husband kanye west and back in
2018 she dished to et about who north
takes after
she's a gemini so she's a little bit of
both she definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or
who it might offend
um and then she's also really calm and
sweet like me sometimes
[Music]